hi my name is Grace I work on the
Android browser today I will show you
some tricks on Android browser you want
to go visit your friend in Google you
found that I dress on the website but
it's not highlighted so you cannot click
it don't worry this is android browser
you just need to click the address it
take you directly to the map hitter the
bag you back to the browser tap the
phone number you go to the dealer you
can call the phone number now you know
in a bottom of the browser you want to
scroll to the top instead of a keep
scrolling you can use a quick soon just
tap here and then move this window all
the way up to here and then release your
finger voila you are on the top then you
notice your paragraph half of it is of
the screen don't worry tap on the tags a
move it to the middle of the screen